these weird times that we're living in
with the corona virus and the pandemic
these are very weird times there's gonna
be a very small community of people I
guarantee you that are sitting around
saying I don't know why I'm optimistic
about something good happening for me
around the corner
everybody's telling me it's the end of
the world zombies gonna be running out
here soon
apocalypse Armageddon whatever you want
to call it all these videos going viral
and posing so much fear I think
everything's gonna be all right
okay that small community post pandemic
a crazy opportunity is gonna present
itself to them and they're gonna
capitalize but it's also gonna be
majority of people in the world who
during these times are gonna get softer
they're gonna get casual they're gonna
pick up bad habits they're gonna watch
so much TV they're probably going to put
on five to ten percent of their body
weight gaining 5 10 15 20 pounds of
weight just get a little bit more you
know casual with their energy and that
opportunity is also gonna present itself
to those people but they're not gonna be
ready for it
my challenge to you is don't take these
times lightly and get caught and glued
to the TV watching every other news as
if you have any major influence to be
able to slow this thing down unless if
you're somebody that's directly working
with Pharma or directly working with
scientists or Falchi or the president
unless if you're somebody involved with
helping come up with the cure keep at it
study every single thing that's going on
but if you're not this is a very good
time to recreate yourself so when that
great opportunity presents itself you
capitalize I have broken out of so many
of my normal routines which is
interesting because I'll caveat this and
I'll tell you what how I'm breaking out
I think routines is probably one of the
things people need to hold on to and I
think that there's there's a big risk
for people that just sort of get in a
weird place
if you don't force yourself to get up
and be productive and do that but
because I am so good at routines and
habits and I'm so regimented and I don't
need like to be pushed or encouraged
like I'm very disciplined in that way
because of that I'm creating new habits
and things around something that's more
playful that's
more fun because I wanted to it would be
all too easy to look back on this time
and say that was a time this this is not
not good this is really gnarly and so I
thought I need to go out of my way to
make this a special time something that
I would look back on and be like yo this
is really fun and so normally I work
from the time I wake up till the time I
go to bed I'm either working or working
out but I've actually introduced play
time and so now I'm working till about
7:00 7:30 and then for the last hour and
a half to two hours it's me my wife and
my sister playing watching something fun
playing video games whatever are you
doing anything like that yeah yeah I
think you know like we know that the
front line work is the doctors the
nurses the you know I've seen you post
about this too and everyone who's like
going out there so that we can all be at
home and be safe like I think everyone
is at home it's a good opportunity for
us to make the most of that use time
wisely because there's a lot of people
who still have to go to work so I think
first of all if you don't have to go to
work or you have to work from home
that's in itself a good opportunity to
engage and for me it's been very much
similar to what you're saying so I've
kept my morning routine pretty much the
same and if anything I'm exercising more
cuz I have more time to exercise so I
can get to workouts in a day when I
usually only do one so that's been quite
refreshing and the evenings are exactly
that so right now it's me and my wife
and one of her best friends and who's
also my friends staying with us and
we've been like you know we've been
having movie nights a couple of nights a
week we've been having a book club night
a couple of nights a week we're reading
different books and discussing and then
we've been having game nights twice a
week too and it's like you know it's I
think people don't need to think that
because of social distancing they can't
have a social life and by creating a
virtual social life you still feel
connected and you get to laugh and play
and and joke around and do all the rest
of it I mean you know I've been saying
this I've been getting into the
PlayStation time which I haven't played
for like I haven't played PlayStation
properly for like seven years I've been
amazing
I really got into it my collection games
my game collection strong right now and
and I'm glad that we're talking about
this because I'm guessing everyone who
is gonna show up on this chat doesn't
think me and you're gonna be sitting
here talking about games but but I'm
hoping that ever lose listening the
reason why we're doing this is because I
just want you to know that there is a
need to do that as well for not in
replacement of right it's not replacing
the routine it's not replacing the work
ethic it's because of this special
scenario that we're in right now that
we're allowing ourselves I'm catching up
on this seven years that I haven't
played FIFA in in like the last three
weeks but I'm also at the same time
using my energy to work on myself
meditate longer workout more get all of
that in as well so just to adjust a
clarifying in case anyone was wondering
if me and Tom have gone wrong and I look
for new opportunities so it's one thing
if you are playing defense and for
example you're building up an emergency
fund do that first prioritize that it's
another thing if you've already been
doing the plan and executing it which
I've been of course I can do my own plan
for a long time so then I said to myself
alright I acknowledge reality I made
plans I took care of my family what now
let's start looking for opportunities
and honestly I don't know what those
opportunities will turn out to me I'm
here I'm chatting with you guys I love
doing this I'm getting more DMS than
ever I'm having fun
so who knows what this turns into I'm
also well I'm watching a lot of TV is
that going to lead to any new
opportunities vanderpump probably not
but we can always hope the point here is
there's a certain point once you have
finished playing defense where you can
actually play offense and you know one
of the opportunities I would say is that
I WT as a company is donating a huge
amount that is an opportunity that I
would not have thought about and we can
only do because we spend a lot of time
building the company
being profitable so Mikey rule number
three look for opportunities and what I
mean by that is don't only play defense
when you've once you've checked the
boxes playing defense start to look for
opportunities whether it's to learn a
new skill develop deeper relationship
with your friends talk to them every
week on zoom' whatever look for
opportunity what are your thoughts about
knowing that sometimes we almost need
these tough times to filter out the weak
from the strong and new leaders being
born during times like this well I think
you said it that's a very good question
because the one thing that nauseum
talent talked about with anti fragile an
anti fragile person will seek
uncertainty they'll always test
themselves you know what happened what
can't I do
what does what do I need to learn you
know they want to test their abilities
where as a fragile person will always
seek protection they will not come out
they'll never metamorphosize you know
they'll be this caterpillar but never
more to metamorphosize into a butterfly
in many fact many caterpillars turn into
hearth worms that go deeper and they
hide you know one of the guys I studied
was Castro and Che Guevara and those
were interesting dudes I mean there were
killers but so I've I may sound silly
but I followed Rivera's path you know
you know around he carried the same
weapon idea in Vietnam I thought that
was a lawful automatic about 30 Cal him
and one carbine
that's what I care they gave me a 38
special it's his lost I just lost you
I'm here okay well anyway what Rivera
found out because he went from Cuba to
you know Bolivia and he tried to get the
peasants to rise up and I knew a guy who
was there when they killed him and he
said you know Rivera had maggots in him
he was so shot up and so wounded but he
never stopped fighting and he was
fighting for the peasants to rise up
like the dead in Cuba and so said what
do you think Grif are well learned he
says well you can't motivate peasants
and he says what worked in Cuba was
there was a middle class with money when
you think about it what's happening
today with this coronavirus is the
peasants will stay peasants that we're
peasant comes from the work pays off
Treach pay is land
salt is person of the land and there's
this gonna stay peasants instead of
getting bigger thoughts us shrink I mean
I have family members like that highly
educated people but instead of pushing
out of the cocoon they're gonna pull
back but the only saw the purse the
reason it worked in Cuba was there was a
middle class and the middle class had
something to lose interesting huh very
very interesting so very good my friend
who was what with the team that killed
Rivera he said that was a tough son of a
[ __ ] the trouble was he was trying to
motivate peasants and I've always cared
that as a lesson nothing the right or
wrong good or bad but some people just
don't have the heart of a warrior
it's not right or wrong it's just they
don't have it they're good people you
know
hard-working people but they don't want
to fight what advice do you give for
people who are isolated at home maybe
they're getting at their partner a
little bit more reactive more is it good
to do cold therapy when you're already
stressed or is there something else that
you ring them called therapy breathing
therapies are to activate the body and
indeed and that goes past the our
conditions physiology so what I say
there is this is time or there's change
happening and this is own world scale
and it is a
it is about our consciousness our
perception our neurology and our
neurology in in the future needs to
become more aware we have to become more
aware of who we are what we are what is
the purpose of life what is nature
what is love because there is the
purpose and we are growing towards that
everything stands still guys stop it
it's over it's done Mother Nature has
come and she says children stop at the
moment because this is not development
this is destruction in the world this
now is a time of opportunity to go
within and to reconnect with a new
paradigm with a new neurology and that
new neurology perception consciousness
is a consciousness of love of equal
division in the world equal
communication backgrounds don't deeper
anymore because we all have a mind which
needs to be much more in connection with
our heart say the mother in New York is
the same as the mother in Baghdad they
just want happiness strength health the
love of life for their children and they
should be able to guarantee that and
that is what I'm working at like
lightworkers but because we talk about
light everybody oh wait this is too much
for me
I go by science I want factual I go by
science I am factual and these
professors after investigating the the
functioning of the brain at will see
that we have come to a new possible
neurology a new control wherein we at
will are able to tap into our brain the
seat of the mind in into the deepest and
wind
actually everywhere and that is going to
be the new paradigm where people are
able to control within their own brain
so much more and you know in the end
when people have control within their
own mind deeper stronger and better
what would they choose would they choose
they unhappy a set of lifestyle or a
happy a set of lifestyle because people
are going to be within their control I'm
already dead Lee studies I'm just a
pioneer I just show beyond speculation
what the human brain and a human will is
possible within that brain within the
mind and if people have a real choice
between having 10 cars or happiness they
are going to yeah if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there well
first of all we're getting much more
radiation naturally than 5g is giving